il est beau comme un camion plein
d'essence
au volant Stéphane darbes il va livrer
une station-service
sur la route il se fait souvent
remarquer donc là on voit
ça les voitures ça remonte à peu près à
800 mètres d'ici et là le monsieur de la
station-service vient tout juste
d'annoncer et bah qui avait plus de
carburant donc les gens vont partir
chercher une autre station parce qu'il y
a pas d'autres solutions
j'ai un taxi qui m'a interpellé juste à
côté à côté de moi pour savoir où c'est
que j'allais donc oui oui c'est le même
souvent
vous arrivez pas à parler
c'est 50 euros voilà Monsieur faut
penser aux autres c'est juste penser à
moi demain matin
un truc donc on pensait covid et là on
pense qu'au plein
et là donc vous nous servez le couplet
qu'on a entendu aussi plein de fois
c'est par cette pour parce que vous
pensez à tout le monde aux gens qui
habitent à côté des raffineries tout ça
c'est bien bravo vous êtes on vous a
bien aiguë à la CGT vous avez dû prendre
des cours pour vous [ __ ] d'oeil du
monde c'est très bien mais nous on croit
pas de toute façon on y croit pas vous
avez envie de bloquer le pays je suis
désolé c'est plus de la grève c'est du
blocage de les pays et la prise de
tâches c'est un terme très fort mais qui
correspond à la réalité pour l'instant
qui est très malhonnête et théoriquement
d'abord parce que un preneur d'otage est
un criminel là ou un grévistes exerce un
droit constitutionnellement reconnu
deuxièmement un preneur d'otage a
nécessairement tort parce qu'il prend en
otage et qu'il commet donc une
infraction pénale
à grévistes n'a pas nécessairement tort
et il peut y avoir tort ou raison au cas
par cas
leur bonheur avec le salaire qu'ils ont
et je crois que plus ils en ont plus là
en faux j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont
mettre en colère c'est tout à fait
croyez moi que
j'envoie devant moi parce que il aurait
C4 vérités en face
je vais t'expliquer je travaille à la
RATP avant je sais ce que c'est le
syndicat d'accord ce qui vous paye c'est
total donc normalement on ne mord pas la
main de celui qui donne à manger on est
d'accord ou pas donc au final mais on
n'est pas là pour moi on est là
bon alors là cette
iconique et puis c'est confortable c'est
rudement confortable effectivement toute
la journée on pourrait rester des heures
ça me dérange pas de vous apporter le
reposer
comme ça au moins vous avez la totale
alors là c'est cool au cas où tu
n'aurais pas compris ce qui se passe
quand il y a un rapport de force dans un
dans un dans un pays et quand des des
salariés des des vols faire reconnaître
leurs droits le but c'est quand même que
on emmerder tout le monde le but c'est
quand même que des gens soient gênés
fini la petite auto
fini les vacances au crottoir
fini le
tiercé c'est pourquoi mes amis si vous
avez des revendications de salaire à
formuler vous m'adressez une note écrite
et je la fous au panier on en parle plus
nous sommes bien d'accord dans la
matinée totale propose finalement par
communiquer 6 % d'augmentation pour ses
salariés français en 2023 ainsi que le
versement d'un bonus exceptionnel à tous
ces salariés correspondant à un mois de
salaire réponse du secrétaire général de
la CGT la revendication qui est sur la
table c'est 10%. le groupe Total énergie
a publié un communiqué rappelant que les
opérateurs total gagnant moyen un
salaire de 4300 euros par mois et qui a
augmenté de 3,5% en janvier suite à ce
chiffre qui a suscité un vif débat les
internautes ont décidé de dévoiler leur
salaire sur Twitter je gagne 1500 après
25 ans à la poste je touche 986 euros
par mois en tant qu' envoyer de station
essence infirmier 11 ans d'ancienneté
horaires décalées travaillent un
week-end sur deux 2100 euros par mois
vous allez toucher 2 millions d'euros
quelques semaines après votre vote pour
le Qatar est-ce qu'il y a un lien entre
ces deux événements
de France 2 tiens je vais vous répondre
qu'est-ce que je m'en fous de France 2
il n'y a pas de lien entre ces deux
événements c'est ce que je comprends de
votre réponse non j'ai dit qu'est-ce que
je viens de [ __ ] de France 2
j'espère que ça passera
il pèse 12 kg comme tous les ballons
[Rires]
merde oui oui je suis nul
voilà pardon
et le Ballon d'Or de la 506e cérémonie
je suis désolé d'insister monsieur le
platiné c'est une simple question est-ce
qu'il y a un lien entre ces deux
millions d'euros et votre vote en faveur
du Qatar qu'est-ce que j'ai à [ __ ] de
France 2